MAKE SPEAKER 1:
Thanks to everyone
for being here for this talk
about River Blindness Disease,
and how technology is helping
to end this age old scourge that
effects 37 million
people in Africa.
I'd like to introduce
Dr. Moses Katabarwa,
a senior epidemiologist
[INAUDIBLE]
for the Carter Center, who's
leading the fight against river
blindness, and who
has spent the last 20
years of his life fixated on
the tiny black fly that carries
the parasite that's
causes river blindness.
Moses Katabarwa is a
native used Ugandan,
a medical anthropologist and
renowned public health expert,
providing scientific support for
the fight against such diseases
as a river blindness, lymphatic
filarisasis-- which is also
known as elephantitis--
and schistosomiasis.
He worked with Oxfam, World
Vision International, and River
Blindness Foundation--
and has been
a speaker on behalf of the CDC.
And currently, also,
is a adjunct professor
at Emory University.
He has a Master's degree and
Doctorate in Anthropology
from the Commonwealth
Open University in the UK;
received his Master's
in Public Health
degree from Rollins
School of Public Health
at Emory University; and was
awarded Emory University's
Sheth Distinguished
International Alumni Award.
Please help me welcome
Dr. Moses Katabarwa.
[APPLAUSE]
DR. KATABARWA: Good
morning, and thank you
for inviting us--
my colleague Ahana.
We're here about the topic
of ending-- of end the age
old scourge.
And River Blindness is
not the disease of places
that you look at and
sanitation is bad
and everything looks bad.
No, it's places
that are pristine.
It is found in
pristine environment.
That's why I emphasizing the
photograph on the screen.
Of course Daniel Wright
has done a lot for us.
And he's a member of the
Global [? Oncho ?] Busters.
And you are welcome to join.
And once you join, you
are a lifetime member.
And this is the distribution
of River Blindness,
or Onchocerciasis.
And this is where
The Carter Center
involved in combating
this disease.
In fact, in the
Western hemisphere,
we are left with
this small place.
Actually, not a small place,
but few people, in the Amazon.
Largely the Yanomami--
between Venezuela and Brazil.
This is how the
disease presents.
This is a young
man, 13 years old.
And you can see on this
side of the-- of the leg,
this is where the
worms are in the leg.
And he's scratching
on that side.
When the worms die, they
cause an immune reaction.
And he has more of these worms
on this side of the body,
and so he's scratching
and creating
secondary infections
that are causing this.
And this is a nodule where the
female and the male worm live.
The female produces
thousands of baby worms.
This is in nematode worm.
This is called leopard skin.
If you go and find someone
who was not burnt in fire,
or something like
that, and he has
this kind of white skin,
which we call leopard skin,
that's Onchocerciasis.
And this called-- we
call this hanging groins.
But you can see how the
skin looks very rough.
We even call it elephant skin.
And River Blindness can cause
these terrible hydroceles.
A [INAUDIBLE], for
instance does it,
but-- or so, this
disease causes it.
And of course, you become blind.
And a patient with
River Blindness--
when they are
getting blind, they
see as if they are in a tunnel.
They have what we
call tunnel vision.
And this is the only disease
that causes this tunnel vision
before, of course,
you get blind.
And it has, also, complications.
And there's a competition
called Nakalanga Syndrome.
This is dwarfism.
And this guy's 28 years old,
and this, also-- this guy's
28 years old.
And the difference
between this, is
that this one has never grown.
He's a child.
He has never developed secondary
sexual characteristics,
so he'll never marry,
he'll never have a kid,
he's actually a child with no
pubic hair-- nothing like that.
And then, this disease
can also cause epilepsy.
And the extreme seizures,
recently mentioned
called, Nodding Disease.
If you Google
Nodding Disease, you
will see how terrible it can be.
We don't know whether it's
associated with this disease,
but some people
already believe that it
is associated with
River Blindness.
And this is 99-- over 99
of the cases are in Africa.
And this is former
Onchocerciasis Control Program,
that was initiated in
1974, and closed 20-- 2002.
And this is the African
program for them.
Onchocerciasis Control
that was initiated in '97,
and is expected close in 2025.
And these are the countries
that Carter Center
has-- is assisting.
And they have launched-- instead
of controlling the disease,
they are out to eliminate
the disease where
it can be found in
these countries.
Uganda is at the forefront of
Onchocerciasis elimination,
or River Blindness elimination.
We've got 3.5 million
at risk, Sudan--
about this-- that is Sudan
North, Ethiopia-- at least 31
million people at the risk.
We know that the mapping is not
complete as I will show you.
Nigeria-- 37.4, the
America's, of course,
we are almost finishing
the job there.
But I'll be showing you
where we need Google.
We use a tablet called
Ivermectin, provided my Merck
Company.
It's donated free as long
as it is it required,
and as much as needed.
And so when you give
it to once a year--
a one dose a year
per person, you
are controlling the disease.
You are not stopping
transmission.
But when you give it twice,
you are after transmission.
You want to control
transmission,
and the worms in someone's body.
But if you are doing vector
control, or vector elimination
with a-- by a biodegradable
agent called, Temephos,
you finish the job faster.
Twice a year with a tablet--
you take six to seven years.
But with the vector
control, you probably
bring it down to three years.
Or two years to
control transmission.
And then you can
continue treating
for the next, maybe, two years.
And then you are done
with-- we are done.
And this is how these worms
look like in the body--
in someone's body.
The female worm is very long,
and lives for ten to 12 years.
Now, if you have
all these people,
and you take them to
health facilities--
medical facilities, the medical
facilities will get clogged
and will shut down.
So what we do is treat people--
train people, and treat them
within their communities.
So they learn how to do it.
They determine the
dosage, they record,
we provide the medicine, they
treat, and take the records
back to health units.
And through the health
units, we get reports.
And order for more tablets.
And-- so this is
a teacher training
people in the community
under Mango tree.
That's the way it should be.
And that's where they
should be treated from.
And we don't even use
scales, like in the hospital,
to determine dosage.
We use a stick as a
surrogate for weight-- height
as a surrogate for weight.
And doing research, we
realized that we could actually
let weight by height.
And so using any stick
calibrated will do.
And we don't have
to pay for that.
Again, when you come to
these local communities--
their neighborhoods,
you discover
that women get involved
and become very active.
And so this is the stick at not
cost-- was got from the bush.
We helped-- the supervisor
helped to calibrate it,
he's also a village person.
And they are treating
their own community.
This is river
gauging to determine
the amount of chemical
you can put in the river
to clean the larval
stages of the black fly.
I'll be showing
you the black fly
is a vector for this nematode.
And this is how
they are using it.
We don't need planes.
Like, in the 70's, they
used planes, in West Africa,
to dose rivers with
this a bit, but now we
use knapsacks sprayers,
train the villagers,
and they do it-- show
them how to do it.
This is how beautiful
an environment where
Onchocerciasis, or River
Blindness looks like.
You are all invited
to come and visit.
Especially, where
there's no transmission.
It's beautiful country.
And this is called Simulium
damnosum, a damn nuisance.
It bites like a bulldog.
And as it tears your
body, the nematode worm
gets inside your body.
And this is how it looks like.
The larval stages, and
when the debris, and what,
in the rivers.
And you can even see
the flies flying off.
It needs a crab in
it's life cycle--
to complete the life cycle.
I'm showing you these
flies because they
are vectors for the disease.
And this is how you trap crab.
This is a crab trapping device--
locally made by communities.
Actually, you trap
mud fish with this.
And now they have adapted
it to trapping crabs.
And they use them
to monitor where
the transmission has
been interrupted.
If they are clean then we know
there's no flies breeding.
This is Uganda, and the
control, from 1992 to 2007.
And Ugandans failed to know--
we must do something else.
We cannot continue
treating endlessly.
And in 2007, they launched
elimination as a policy
for the country.
And see where we are-- all
these places are clean.
Now I zeroed here because the
gentlemen here in the Google
gave me a Google image.
Because we can't go across to
DR of C there is DR of C----
the Democratic
Republic of Congo.
And I couldn't prove that
there was-- Congo was free.
Because you need the
forest for the nice fly--
the gold plated fly.
You need the forest
that's where it survives.
It's a shy [INAUDIBLE]
cord environment.
This is what we have done--
Carter Center assisted
problem in the Americas.
And our issue here, is here.
This is the problem.
But all these are green
areas-- you can see.
So we are left with very little
in-- but very challenging
in the Western Hemisphere.
And this is Ethiopia.
All of this area is unmapped.
Communication is difficult.
But this area is mapped.
So what is going in the
blue and yellow areas?
And we have started distributing
twice bi-annually the medicine.
Here it's still control.
And this area needs
some refinement mapping.
No work is going on, and so
there's a lot of work to do.
And if we complete
mapping, we will probably
have at least 60 million
people at risk in Ethiopia.
Already where we are,
there are about 31 million.
So the challenges-- we still
have vast unmapped areas--
especially where countries
have country-wide elimination
policy.
And WHO will not to verify River
Blindness Elimination for just
a small place.
They need to verify
for the entire country.
And then we have cross-border
transmission issues.
And for some countries,
mapping agencies
have not updated their maps.
And we need this type of maps.
And sometimes they're
not available.
Where are the communities?
Sometimes it's a
jungle, like the Amazon.
Where are the communities
that are affected.
Mapping Onchocerciasis
is warranted
when an area is inhabited.
Because the human
disease-- we need
to find-- if there are humans.
That's when we go
to the mapping.
But if you don't
have the technology,
you will go and find nobody.
And you will have been
wasting resources.
But if you have
technology and you
know-- you can tell that
there are communities,
then you can go where
you-- where you already
know that there are communities.
Technical Challenges--
clean image acquisition--
rivers, roads, forests,
homes, fields--
we want to be able to-- Because
it's associated with fast
running water, you need
to see white water.
You need see, because white
water means way oxygenated
water.
That's where the fly likes,
because of enough oxygen
for it's eggs.
Cloud cover
penetration-- I will show
you some of the-- the
Amazon is an example.
How do you penetrate the clouds?
Distinguishing
communities from other
cleared areas of the forest.
Distinguishing active from
abandoned Yanomami communities
in the Amazon.
Are there features--
smoke, for example,
characteristic over
an active community?
Can we tell?
Penetration of the forest
canopy to extract signals
from the heavily
forested streams.
In the case of some flies
like Simulium neavei--
the gold plated, which it
likes forest environment.
How to get signals from
lower resolution-- more
cost effective images.
What about cloud cover?
Can we develop algorithms
to extract useful data
from images with
significant cloud cover?
Can we quantify the predictions?
Can we develop ways to
predict the sites that
will be the most
productive breeding sites?
Extension of this
approach, if we succeed,
it can be used in many diseases.
Especially vector born diseases.
Here we call them NTD's or
neglected tropical diseases.
So the potential
for this technology,
if we can get to it, is--
the uses is limitless.
Here in USA, can we develop
signals for chrysops--
spray deer fly.
Breeding sites such
as soil moisture,
and high organic content.
And all these are
places that they
fly-- that the Deer
Fly will thrive.
This is the, kind
of, Yanomami Village,
I don't-- if I'd call
it-- in the Amazon.
Can we identified these?
Then, does Google have this?
This is very interesting.
The satellites collect
several bands of information.
In each pixel examined, based
on the relative reflectance,
observes in each pixel
among the different bands.
Spectral signatures
can be identified
that are diagnostic for
particular landscape features.
And I will leave this
information for you
to go it in details.
And this is what the
pixel reflectance
looks like for the breeding site
of Simulium, or the black fly.
Where we see this
pattern, reflectance
will predict that
the suitable breeding
site is the habitat for
the-- exists for the fly.
And this is Damnosum,
the black-- they are all
called black flies, but one
is a black, another one's gold
plated-- so the black one.
This is the satellite.
What we did here--
we had applied
this to identify Simulium
damnosum breeding sites where
the landscape
characteristic is fast
flowing water over
precambrain rock substrate.
So the upper panel shows an
area in a satellite image,
of such a habitat.
The lower panel is
a ground photograph
of the breeding site.
And then, when we went to
this for ground truthing,
we realized that the
precambrain rocks
seem to be the best habitat
for the breeding of Simulium
damnosum, the black--
the fly which is black.
And the paper will be,
if you're interested,
it's already published.
You can look at it.
There are great uses
for all this stuff.
And there are two
things I want show here.
This is my-- this forest
is about 40 kilometers
from my home-- where I was born.
It's a beautiful place and they
call it [SPEAKING UGANDAN]--
means leaving you speechless.
So that is a Onchocerciasis,
or River Blindness, area.
Do you see this?
This is a-- called [? Bindi ?]
Impenetrable Forest--
a tropical forest.
And this is the border-- this
is Uganda-- this is DR of C.
How do I prove that this
forest-- Because you need
the forest for the
fly that's transmits
this disease in this
area, and I wanted
to show them that in
DR of C, the forest has
been disseminated, so
the ecology's gone.
So how do we verify
this as transmission
interrupted of this disease?
And thank God, there
was Google around.
And there was my friends here.
And we're able to prove--
and the color-- this area now
has moved from transmission
active to suspected
interrupted transmission.
Now, if you're talking about
the disease verification,
that's a big deal.
That's a big deal.
It means that now
you are free to go
to this place for tourism.
This is a mount-- this is
where you find your mountain
gorillas.
So-- you can promote
tourism here now.
So let's go to the
next Google map.
So we can-- using
these images, we
can actually be able to
see what is happening
across the board of where
we are not allowed to go.
This is Venezuela
and this is Brazil.
This is the Amazon.
So those-- the challenges they
have-- already mentioned above,
apply to this place.
How can we make-- how can
we identify communities
that have never been identified?
But when you go to the Yanomami,
they tell you, oh, this
is not the only village,
there are more villages.
But you know, for
them a day-- can you
quantify a day-- a day's
walk in terms of miles.
We can't.
And to get in here, they
are using helicopters
from the Venezuelan Army.
And they go whenever
they have a reason to go.
They don't go because
you want to go and check
on these Yanomami.
So having good image we
can identify these places.
We can go in and train
the Yanomami, provide
the medicines, and
everything they need.
And treat them.
And clear the Western
Hemisphere of this scourge.
You can see-- for
Ethiopia, on this side
of the country we
have done pretty
well in mapping the area.
But when it comes
to this area, which
is like half of the
country, we have challenges.
And communication--
if we are to go here,
you need to know
where is the road.
Because in some places,
we did mapping--
like in the case of Uganda,
it was done on foot.
The roads were impassable.
Uganda had just come out of war.
Everything had been
destroyed and neglected.
And to map this disease,
70% was done on foot,
like the explorers
in the 15th century.
But things have changed.
You know, in 21st century
should we do that?
You just to go, spend a whole
week looking for communities,
and you can't find them.
Yet when we use
these Google Maps,
we can actually see where
the community-- active
communities-- where they are.
We can see their fields-- where
they're growing some food.
We can tell their
communities, and we can also
be able to see rivers.
You can even enlarge and in this
area you will see some rivers.
The images look so good now.
But you can see the potential.
Potentially, that
this is a high land.
You can see the
gorges, the valleys,
and you can see these in-- they
like to be fast running rivers.
And then, if we can connect
with the communities,
we can figure out how
do we get to there.
And you can plan ahead
what you need to do.
Do we need to get porters to
carry your tents, and what not,
to go in and check
on these communities
to see whether they have
the disease, or not.
And then provide train--
provide them with medicines.
So all of that stuff--
without Google Maps--
I don't know how we can do it.
I mean we can do it, but
takes years and years.
So those are the
challenges we have.
These we have--
WHO has now agreed
that this disease
can be eliminated.
We have the technology.
We have the medicines.
The technology from mapping,
I'm sure, is available.
We have the army.
The army are the communities--
the affected communities
themselves.
The army against this disease.
So we have the political
will from these countries.
So, I think what we
need is to get people
who are interested in
this kind of technologies
to help us-- put
our heads together
and to get rid of
this age old scourge.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER 2: Are there any
side effects to the pills?
And could you give them to
people as a preventive measure,
even if they don't show
any signs of disease?
DR. KATABARWA: If they don't
show any sign of disease,
there aren't serious
side effects.
However, there is
another disease
called Loa Loa, which
is in the-- no matter
in forested countries.
And once you take Ivermectin,
you can get a severe reaction.
But there are, also, ways of
managing the severe reactions.
But for those who
have the disease,
and have an active
immune system--
first time-- a few days, because
when you take the medicine
it lasts about
two or three days.
So those first two days
can be really tough.
Because, the medicine is
killing the baby worms,
and your immune system is
reacting to the dead baby
worms.
And therefore,
you'll get what we
call, localized or
extensive body sweating.
And you also itch and
scratch-- by the way,
but you scratch for-- itch
and scratch for two days,
and then you are fine.
But this a disease-- one of
the symptoms is scratching.
So people scratch day and night.
They use stones or hot
water-- boiling hot water
and pour on themselves, so
they can stop the scratch.
And it doesn't stop.
They use stones--
scratch and scratch,
you bleed, you
continue scratching.
So, it is worth it to scratch--
itch and scratch for two days,
and then you get
over it, than have--
you know, your entire-- your
entire life you are scratching
and-- itching and scratching?
MAKE SPEAKER 3: I
want to know, is
the end goal, the complete
elimination of the black flies?
Is that what you're
trying to achieve?
DR. KATABARWA: No, in some areas
which we have deemed feasible,
we have aimed at it, and
eliminated the fly-- especially
in Uganda.
But our aim is really
not to eliminate the fly.
Especially, when
it's not feasible.
But once we attack the fly,
we reduce its population,
and it's capacity to transmit.
So if you combine that
strategy with the medicine,
we can actually get rid of the
nematode, one, which transmits.
And once the worm is
going, then the fly
can thrive if it
wants to thrive.
FEMALE SPEAKER: You mentioned
how useful spectral imaging
could be, and I
wasn't sure-- were
you saying that you
found a reliable source
of spectral imaging
in these remote areas,
or are you still
searching for a source?
DR. KATABARWA: You mean
in terms of technology?
FEMALE SPEAKER:
Right, the satellite
with extra information
in each pixel--
DR. KATABARWA: It
is damn expensive.
For a small area, it's thousand
and thousands of dollars.
And I don't think
Carter Center-- I mean,
we'll run bankrupt.
So the study was funded
by the government of USA.
And my colleague,
Professor Tom Unnash,
from the University of South
Florida, and other colleagues,
did this study in Burkina Faso
in Uganda-- Northern Uganda,
and we found it works.
But the technology
is very expensive.
But suppose we study
other diseases.
And is there a way of
reducing the expenses.
Can we make this technology
less-- more effective,
but the less expensive?
That would be great.
MALE SPEAKER 4: When
someone has the disease,
I see there's a lot of
different effects on them--
with the bumps, and the itching,
and then, the blindness.
When they take the medicine,
do those symptoms go away.
Does their sight return, or
are those permanent conditions?
DR. KATABARWA: Once
the-- you have--
because it's a progression
for visual impaired--
it halts vision impairment.
So you don't proceed.
You stop where you are.
But if you're blind,
your remain blind.
If you have the bad skin,
and of course, itchiness,
which really increases the
level of the rough skin.
All of those stop, and you
can actually regain your skin.
But if you have gone to a level
where how have hanging goins--
the skin is hanging.
It has lost its elasticity.
You can't recover.
You just remain--
you get healed,
but you remain with that
issue throughout you life.
And once you have leopard skin,
you remain with leopard skin.
The nodules can go away.
And actually, we
have found, where
we've been treating
the nodules which
appear on bony prominences--
your ribcage, around the groins
here, and sometimes on your
forehead-- those ones go.
Because the worms
are so-- are dying.
And therefore, there's no
more worms being retained
and growing up to
their adult stage.
And the tragedy is that
the environment where
you find this
disease, is where'd
you would want to
build your home.
And school attendance-- how
do you scratch day and night?
You get to a point where
you-- you lose your senses.
You become irrational.
That's the nature
of this a disease.
Doesn't kill very
rapidly like HIV,
but as you walk-- If
you have this disease,
you walk in San Francisco as
a dead body-- on the street.
So that's how it kills you,
and keeps you walking around.
So, is that the best way
of describing the disease?
That you don't-- it doesn't kill
you so that you are buried--
no.
You can live up to even 60
years, 70 years-- but everyone
will reject you.
You're a destitute in
your own community.
You are scratching
and-- we say back home,
if you want to scratch
yourself, don't scratch yourself
before your mother-in-law.
This is a disease
makes you scratch
before your mother-in-law--
shamelessly.
So that's how bad
it's going to be.
[APPLAUSE]